نقعد الان الى ملعب لوسيل في قطر حيث
تتواصلوا مباراه نهائي كاس العالم قطر
2002 و20 بين المنتخبين الفرنسي
والارجنتيني والتي تشهدوا تعادل بين
منتخبا الارجنتين وفرنسا الفريقان يبحثان
عن اللقب اذا الثالث في تاريخهما واضافه
نجمه ثالثه الى سجله عن الاجواء في
يونس ايرس تحديدا الان ينضم الينا اذا
مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود حسان يبدو ان
الاجواء الان مغيره لما كان في بدايه هذه
النشره
بالفعل مياده هذا المونديال يبدو انه مصر
على الا ينتهي الا بالكثير من المفاجات
وكانت اكبر هذه المفاجات تسجيل فرنسا
لهادفين خلال خمس دقائق فقط من الوقت ما
قبل انتهاء الصوت الثاني لهذه المباراه
بعدما كانت الارجنتين متقدمه بهدفين
المشهد هنا ان اردنا ان نظهر لكم الصوره
فهي اكثر هدوءا اكثر صمطا
ارجنتينيين في هذه اللحظات صامتون هادئون
لا يعلمون ما ستكون عليه الحاله بعد
صفاره انتهاء هذا الشوط ربما او حتى هذه
المباراه همم كما رايته يعني التعبير
الاوضح منهم هو الصدمه هو الاستغراب من
هذه النتيجه التي انقلبت سريعا وباتت
هدفين مقابل هدفين لمنتخب الارجنتين
ومنتخب فرنسا كانوا ينتظرون ان الحلم همم
بات بمتناول اليد همم ان يحصلوا على الكاس
كاس العالم للمره الثالثه على يد قائد
منتخبهم وهذا المنتخب الذي يعولون عليه
كان بمتناول اليد لكنهم الان ينتظرون
يتراقبون سفاره النهايه ربما ليس في هذا
الشوط ربما في شوطاني اضافيين او حتى
ركلات الجزاء بعد تغير هذا السيناريو ولكن
بكل الاحوال الارجنتينيون هي يقفون حتى
اللحظه الاخيره امام خلف منتخب بهم لتحقيق
هذا الحلم الذي انتظره لسته 36 عاما
السعودي والفرنسيون يبدو انهم تنفس
الصاعده الان
مياده حاله غليان في صفوف من بقي من
الجماهير الفرنسيه في جده الشانزليزي قلنا
ان خيبه امل اصابتهم بعد تسجيلها هدفي
المنتخب الارجنتيني فغادر 43
ساحه قوس النصر وجدت الشانزليزيه ولكن من
بقي متمسكا بالامل هو يعيش اجواء الفرحه
هنالك يعني احتفالات بالشماريخ هنا
وبالفرقعات
طيب همم
السعودي ولكن نترككم ما هذه الصور
المباشره من باريس وهذه الحشود المتواجده
اذا من جماهير المنتخب الفرنسي الذين
يحتفلون بالهدافين
للمنتخب الفرنسي في الشوط الثاني واا
سنعود بالتاكيد لمراسلنا المزيد من تفاصيل
حول هذه الاجواء ولكن نترككم قليلا مع هذه
الصوره
سنعود الان الى تونس ايرس وحسان مسعود
حسان كما ذكرت لربما القلق الان مع هذين
الهدفين يخيم على الاجواء في الارجنتين
ولكن لن نذكر حسان بتاريخ المنتخب في كاس
العالم وما الذي سيحرزه بهذه البطوله
الى هذا المكان وهي تبكي بوركي
ايه نانس يا وظيفه لوري كويس
اوكي ههه
[موسيقى]
اتت الى هنا الان باكيه كانت تقول انها
اتت وهي
مفعمه بالفرحه وتنتظر ان تحتفل مع
المتواجدين هنا على مقربه منا ايه
بالهدفين وبي- اجواء الفوز بكاس العالم
لكنها صدمت وهي في طريقها الى هنا من ان
النتيجه انقلبت وانها الان لم تعد تدري ما
اذا كانت قد اتت وستحتفل ام لا هناك ايضا
مشجعه اخرى تاتي الان مع طفلتها اوكي اوكي
لو قلت مع ناعمه غنمه
هذه لديها روح مختلفه مياده تقول انها
ستين حتى النهايه حتى اللحظه الاخيره مع
حق المباراه حسان تحتاج لهدف واحد فقط
لتحصل على الكاس طيب الاجواء لدى لطفي
المسعودي اكثر ارتياحا ولربما تنقل لنا
ايضا لطفي بعد ردود الفعل
مياده حاله من الخليان والاحتفال بشماريخ
تسبب في بعض المشاحنات الطفيفه بين الشرطه
الفرنسيه والجماهير التي جاءت هنا الحمد
لله ان الامور لم تنفلت بطريقه كليه وتم
سيطره عليها وعادت الجماهير الفرنسيه الى
الاحتفال وهي في حاله غليان معي الان احد
مشاهدي المنتخب الفرنسي الذي عبر بطريقه
كبيره جدا عن فرحته العالمه بعوده المنتخب
الفرنسي في نتيجه المباراه
[تصفيق]
للمونديال وفي الحفاظ على لقبهم المونديال
ويقول انه احيانا جميعا وهنا باريس ونحن
مع المنتخب الفرنسي مياده هنالك اجواء
احتفاليه كبيره على امتداد جده جونزيليزي
لاحظنا ان الجماهير التي غادرت بسبب
الخيبه بعد تسجيل هدفي المنتخب الارجنتيني
عادت مجددا عدد همم الفرنسيين الذين
يتوافدون الان على جده
ويتطور بين اللحظه واخرى وهنالك امال
كبيره في عوده هذا المنتخب في هذه
المباراه بعد ان سجل مبابي هدفي تعديل
النتيجه هم الانثيقون جدا من ان هذا
المنتخب بامكانه صناعه المستحيل بامكانه
الحفاظ على لقبه المنجالي و بامكانه ان
ينتزع ان نجمه الثالثه من الارجنتين ويكون
هو الاسبق وان يحتدي بجاره الايطالي الذي
حقق
دورتين متتاليتين
وان يفرض اسم فرنسا بين كبار لعبه قدم في
العالم
اليوم هو من سيفوز بكاس العالم فرنسا ام
الارجنتين الاجابه ستكون خلال ربما سبع
دقائق من الان الوقت الاصلي قد انتهى
ودخلنا في الوقت الاضافي سنتابع معكم هذا
ايمن الاجواء شكرا لكم اذا من باريس ومن
بونيس ايرث سعود
وايضا حسن مسعود شكرا لكم